- [Announcer 1:] He's been
slow in the last few weeks
going into the shutdown.
That must be the confidence.
How about that?
- [Announcer 2:] That started with
a breakup
of a pass, Brez.
- During the game, after LeBron dunked,
he either said, “I'm still
the baddest out here”
or “I'm still the fastest out here.”
OK, I asked LeBron if he said
that he was still the
baddest or still the fastest.
He looked at me and said,
“What do you think I said?”
- [Flight attendant:] Welcome to Orlando.
The local time is 10:33.
- Most importantly,
always have to start the day with a mask.
[Funky music]
On the way to practice No. 1.
OK, so right now we are
in the Wide World of Sports
on the northwest side, getting ready
to go to Rockets practice.
It's the first practice
that we are going to.
Teams are staggered throughout the day
in different locations, but
Rockets are right now.
- Thank you, Austin.
- Good job, Tracy.
[Laughing]
- We gotta practice, bro.
- Bro, ask him, bro.
He the one that got all
the fuckin’ questions.
Yeah, he the one that got all the questions.
- One question.
- [Austin Rivers:] Goddamn.
- Heading to practice No. 2.
Going to watch the Miami Heat.
- What time is it?
Aw, yeah, it's Mickey time.
[Funky music]
Hold on. Don't get me right now.
My mask not up.
- [Taylor laughing]
- Where we going?
How are you, Taylor?
- I'm fantastic.
- You good?
- [Taylor:] So you said
that it was gonna be TBD
what you do with your jersey.
What was the feeling when it was rejected?
- I mean, we can't say that
I didn't think that it would be a problem.
But, like I said,
I'm hoping that they come
back and see the message
that I want to get out there
and let me speak on something
the way that I would
like to speak on it.
Like I said, to be determined.
We really don't know. I'll
keep pressing for it.
And I hear plenty of other
players around the league
would like to do the same, so
I just, I hope that they see the message
that we want to get across
and they let us be who we are.
Get your ass from
behind the damn screen.
Dunc. Dunc.
- Yo.
- Duncan’s here, ready to go!
- So we know you are big into fashion.
How has that changed in
Orlando or has it changed?
- I brought everything with me, so
I got enough options ready
to have something every day.
- Okay, Tuesday, July 21,
very busy day.
We're headed to Blazers practice first.
[Funky music]
Portland wins the award for best DJ.
Best DJ.
[Hip-hop music]
Lakers practice second.
[Funky music]
So, we know obviously
you're focused on winning,
but we heard Vogel talk about why
you should be Defensive
Player of the Year.
What were your thoughts on what he said,
and what's your case?
- I didn't hear what was said.
What was that?
- Well, what's your case
for why you should get it?
- I don't have a case. I'll let that—
I’ll let my teammates decide
and the fans decide. But
I just go out there and play
hard every night, you know?
My biggest impact that I
think I have is defensively.
I love playing defense. I
love stopping other players,
making it tough on other players. So,
that’s just like my case in a nutshell.
- And we end the day with
the Celtics practice.
[Funky music]
- Get that shit outta here!
- Ah, fuckin' hate you.
- Hey, hey, hey!
- [Taylor:] There we go.
Man, oh, man.
I am exhausted.
Best parts of today:
The Lakers ended their pre-practice huddle
putting hands in and
saying, "One, two, three, Mamba."
That was a really nice,
really, really touching moment.
That was my favorite part of the day.
I think I'm gonna end on that.
This is the first day of
actual basketball play.
Obviously not a game, but a
scrimmage for competition!
Teams facing one another.
I'm looking forward to it, so
I'm heading to the arena right now.
[Laid-back music]
- [Taylor:] On a scale of one to 10,
10 being the most different,
how would you rate playing again?
- An 11.
That was different. You know,
when you come out for warm-ups
and, like, literally no one is out there,
and I went over to some of the referees,
talked to Leon and Scott
a little bit beforehand.
And even then, they were like,
“This is just surreal.”
[Funky music]
- All right, it's Thursday, July 23.
I'm getting ready, as you can see.
Very big day, second day of scrimmages,
I'll be at Bucks-Spurs at 3:00,
then I'll be at Lakers-Mavs at 7:00.
- Hut hut!
- OK, OK.
My man, do that.
- So today, Becky Hammon is the head coach.
I'm loving it. It's definitely
my favorite thing
that I've seen so far in Orlando.
She has complete control of the team.
The guys are listening. They’re soaking
in everything she's saying.
It's great.
Hey, Becky. So once these
scrimmages are over,
what will success look like for you?
Meaning, what will you
have to see to say, “OK,
we got better. These served their purpose”?
- Well, we gotta get better on
the defensive side of the ball.
It's been a struggle for us all year.
We've been poor in transition,
and we've been poor in
the half-court defense.
We gotta get better rim protection.
I mean, you could go down the list.
There's a litany of things
that we could do better defensively,
and I think that's the big growth piece.
- [Taylor:] The cleaning crew.
We washed our hands, but
there's a door, and
obviously we can't touch it
because, you know, COVID-19,
- [Videographer:]
Oh, get the beginning.
Get the beginning!
Get it, get it!
- There we go!
- Gotchu.
- The struggle.
- Victory!
Still asked you initially—
- [Indistinct talking in background]
- Can't hear you.
Louder!
- So if you can hear, "Ether"
by Nas is playing right now.
Matisse Thybulle goes, “Is this Joe Budden?”
[Funky music]
Your mask perfectly fits on your beard.
Yeah, there we go. There we go.
Adidas gotchu right.
- Gang, gang. Forever.
- Hello, camera.
- [Taylor:] Hello, Ben.
- How are you?
- [Taylor:] Great, you?
- Doing well.
[Funky music]
- We're so gonna miss the bus
sitting here vlogging,
talking to you guys.
[Funky music]